safe nest is teaming up with the mexican
consulate to support domestic violence
victims in the immigrant community
the goal is to prevent family violence
especially against women and children
the organizations say the pandemic
caused an increase in domestic abuse
cases
and they want to remind victims that
health is available both in english and
in spanish safe nest reminding everybody
abuse comes in many forms
someone making financial decisions
without you are they taking your
paycheck
and it all starts out in a way that
looks very normal right let me have your
cell phone number so that i can make
sure
i can text you during the day and then
it's 20 ticks and then it's 30 texts and
then it's where are you and then
you're starting to feel anxious that
you're not home on time or you're a
couple minutes later you took longer at
the grocery store and you know there's
going to be a consequence for that
both safe nest and the consulate say
victim's personal information including
legal status will always remain
confidential
if you or someone you know needs help
you can call the number right there on
your screen or you can simply just visit
safenest.org